foreign
[Music]
let's say you and I on the road Godfrey
and Bobby Lee show we're in Cincinnati
all right right we see the most
beautiful girl in the world yeah she's
like I want to make love to both of you
oh right but can we black and yellow
black and yellow black and yellow can we
do it at the same time would you
nah why let you go first not with you
hell no why you'll be like let me get
him back at you
[Laughter]
you have any secrets to keeping it fresh
in the bedroom three kids in you have
any special moves that you do or
anything is there anything that uh you
know you think you specialize in in the
bedroom you have like a move or
something something you do with your
finger or your butthole or something
perhaps I don't know Hans do you love
eating [__] or not
bedtime stories to the kids yeah
yeah wow that is some Jerry Sandusky
[__] if I've ever heard of before
what the [__] dude
talking about
I should clarify to our kids
that's still
while you're reading like I'm getting my
wife so well
you yeah do you know what's coming when
you're reading you're like well I'm
gonna [__] after this
are you like get the [__] to bed
[Applause]
I'll be hard go to bed
for real
do you get hard when you read to your
[__] kids
answer the [__] questions
do you
could answer it'd be no I've never been
posed a question and such that
odds is great these are likable people
man it's incredible it is a likable
bunch here tonight this guy gets hard
while his wife gets wet while they're
reading to their kids
the couch 17 year old kids
still away
son we're gonna Read 50 Shades of Gray
dad please
not again I need this son
I would love to know how Colin lost his
virginity
yeah well tell us well I mean this
it's uh you know in phases but really I
lost watch I lost my virginity the
person how do you lose it in phases
Billy Hayes Billy Hayes uh the great
Billy Hayes is off camera yelling the
front and the Back Billy Hayes who's got
a tooth in his head
he's trying to imply that I lost my
opportunity
[Laughter]
I would be excited I would kind of be
really excited I'd be like hey OJ like
hey can I get a photo I'm a really big
fan no legit just for the Instagram
I mean how many people are doing that by
the way everybody's probably doing that
100 and imagine him thinking like when
he's standing there in court and all
this horrible stuff's coming out I
wonder if he thought hey man this is all
gonna shake out yeah one day Donald
Trump will be the President right right
Bruce Jenner will transition to Caitlyn
and then I'm gonna be in Vegas and
people are going to be actually coming
up to me going hey I'm a big fan the
milk boys had him on the podcast he's
kind of rehabilitated he's kind of
rehabilitated I would literally go up to
O.J Simpson and go I am a huge fan and I
would love a photo and I'm very
confident he decapitated his wife and
her lover but I wouldn't I would
absolutely go up to him and go I am a
huge big fan massive fan of yours
can I get a photo and then I would put
it on my Instagram and try to come up
with a funny caption and I think you
figure it out who's the first famous
person you ever met if Michael Landon
canceled it
um
let me think of who it was that's a
great question I'm gonna be saw
uh
uh probably the DARE officer at our
school but he wasn't like nationally
famous but he was how famous was he he
was like the biggest guy they ever made
in the whole world and what do you mean
when the car would pull up like I
remember one time he like shot people
from the car he couldn't get out of like
the officer vehicle or whatever he's a
huge man he was a oh he was a big fella
he was an obese man and
he and he would come to speak about dare
yeah and he got out of the car but there
were Tales of him at crimes where he'd
just pull up and just start popping off
you know because he couldn't at some
point he couldn't even get out of the
vehicle oh so he'd fire from the vehicle
and open fire so he was like uh in our
area he was pretty popular Ronald Reagan
um was his name you know that'd be crazy
it also happened to be named Ronald
Reagan
does God have sex
does he no one ever thinks no one's ever
asked that question does God have sex
yeah I mean I imagine well because he
has he created it all he must be like
you know I mean I tried you know what I
mean a more viable question would be
does Jesus jerk off
because they made him a figure of a man
well a human form he must have tried it
he probably did it so much that's why
they nailed him at the wrist
you know he died with an erection wow he
died with a hard on that was a knife no
no by the way Jesus was naked all these
depictions of them have him covered he
was they were nude when they did public
and he sort of that public stuff you
were nude there wasn't any like decency
class sure 100 how do you know this but
because I was around
yeah how old are you I'll tell you
exactly how I know yeah in what world
would a Savage brutalization like
nailing someone to Wood and and putting
them up in public for other people to
see die slowly yeah would you have the
decency to be like cover up his penis
you nailed him to Wood that's true you
literally hammered a man's body to
why would you have the psychopathic
decency to go all right don't let his
nuts hang out come on we're not months
yeah we're all animals I wouldn't even
show up to that thing would you to what
the heck to the you see the flyer I'm
kidding they don't give us the Flyers
what you don't got a lot going on that
day I know you went to the market you
got Netflix right there's nothing else
to do that is Netflix right right that's
their Netflix and when they hang them up
they go
I think what Britain has done I think
what the West like America is a bit
different but Britain in particular we
take food from all around the world and
then we add fries to it and we go now
that's English
that's I like I've never been for an
Indian curry and not had fragile really
whatever
your dish are they making it better when
my mom would make bolognese loves Indian
food and loves fries she would love
England white people make everything
better it's like minorities you got the
idea but you just need some white some
mold it into something you know yeah
my mom would make bolognese when we were
growing up and she was really good at it
she would make a place to go would you
like a gay Night Out
San Francisco
and she would make a plate surprise yeah
yeah to go with the Bolognese that's
good of course it's one of the fries bad
it makes everything better and I hate
how they look at you guys like you know
what the [__] you're doing with food I
even say that with British people oh
they don't know what's going on with
food you got the best cooking show on
the planet which is British Bake Off
okay and Gordon Ramsay Gordon Ramsay
Gordon Ramsay's gone off a cliff because
he starts doing tick tocks with his
daughter what's wrong
[Laughter]
sometimes hummus
smells
really bad oh you're so sometimes hummus
smells like body odor or something oh
stop it Sal it never smells like Bo o
does it does it has a very weird you
have a weird smell smell I don't I
shower twice a day I I'm gonna say this
and I say it without exaggeration and
you're not gonna believe me and I
promise you it's true I have never had a
flavored hummus I have only ever bought
and consumed you want to play that game
bro you want to play that I have always
every week
at my home and I've seen you dipping and
I show you can I show you what I did at
the supermarket last week yeah I show
you what I did working last week I went
shopping for the week it was Sunday
actually it was Sunday I went shopping
for the week I was in line it was empty
the store is pretty empty I said to the
lady but it was crowded enough that I
had to move fast I hope these details
the hummus the hummus it does Thomas is
near like to the registers because it's
in the produce section the I said to the
checkout lady I go [__] I forgot to get
hummus she goes go ahead just run and
get it I go thank you there was one guy
behind me I had to be fast I ran to the
hummus section I got there red lid went
right for red lid
they were out of the plane out loud in
the supermarket I go come on like that
and grabbed a different brand because
the other brand had plain and that one
didn't oh my God yeah there's a huge
Chunk in there oh Nick come on here
I'm sorry
I got a big day for me today it's gonna
be a really sad day
for I'm watching the sports thing
at three
go ahead eat it
try it I'm not gonna do it just try it I
just turned 36. try it I'm telling you
it's not good
just do it eat it
just eat it
no don't just eat it please
please
would you please just eat it please
my ear really hurts
will it make will make you feel better
yes
I mean it's not that much yeah just eat
it
you know Nick is really [__]
disgusting look we're not gonna turn
this into a whole thing either you can
eat the earwax or
not we can move on it's fine
I'm not going to demand anything on me
I'm not going to guilt trip you either I
feel like you already are no it's fine
it all feels like it's spreading
but it's ear wax in there it's not
boogers it's fine you get earwax in here
enough it's the same too I'll do it if
you want I would like it if you ate the
earwax thank you
it would mean in the third grade it was
like literally getting paid a dollar a
day do you think in the cafeteria it
would mean a lot to me if you ate the
earwax
please you mean that please
oh
thank you
because
you're going to the next game I remember
the first time I ever got clocked in in
junior high football I got smoked I got
smoked the kicker was hurt and they're
like Santino you can kick you're the
only one that could probably kick I said
I don't want to [__] kick he's like
dude you gotta we have no one else and
kick the [__] football fine so the
kid snaps through the ball goes you know
30 yards over my [__] head and I jump
nothing I turn I grab the ball and I'm
thinking I'm running for the first down
[__] this dude
I'm like oh what I'm doing is crap I got
smoke how many steps did you get before
and did they get you like when you have
oh yeah yeah I was mid-stride I was
horizontal when you got one foot up and
I remember my dad going you got your
bell wrong boy
I think I spoke Chinese for like a month
that one got me back that kid still
talks about that he's like y'all watch
that show Dave and look at this guy over
here I [__] him up in high school man
he's somewhere on a patio smoking a
heater with somebody going yeah you know
that redhead from there that guy right
there
immersed that kid dude
I like that kid's [__] career dude
you really are
but true man I remember dude the whole
team went oh
my team my team oh Santino last time you
had a massage
recent good yeah tell us it's nice on
the road yes uh I was in
I don't I don't remember where but yes
the whole time I was like yeah was it
like an appointment one or you popping
no it was a spa in the hotel ah there
you go yeah yeah that's what I'm talking
I thought I was gonna get whacked off
the whole time man that's every time I'm
just like am I gonna get jerked off and
I'm nervous the whole time yeah you were
in a high end and I laughed I can't stop
laughing every massage I get I laughed
the entire [__] time and I had to
tell it I was like is this normal and
she was like you're the only person no
you're actually just like I've never
done this yeah
it hurts hmm it hurts your body massages
yeah they can't yeah they get in there
[__] dude when's the last time you got
one uh a few weeks ago couples massage
me and him
I did him first
I like to see that I like to see you
treating yourself man he was trying to
get a hand job
how did you come up with it how did it
start so Kippy and I have been uh we've
been friends since we both started
comedy uh in Philly and uh we became
Fast Friends he can be a real trash town
by the way yeah it's a real scumbags
I've never seen [__] human beings a
lot of people wear sweatpants at five
o'clock I don't know what you're talking
it's still one of the cities where you
can just get beat up within like 30
seconds yeah you're just like you got to
keep your head on a swivel anytime you
hear about unprovoked violence and it's
you're like yeah that checks if it's in
Failure like that checks out yeah for
sure they did something trust me if you
don't say thank you to somebody holding
the door for you walk into a Wawa that's
grounds that get popped in the face oh
sure yeah you're welcome and if they
don't say thank you then then it's it's
on site yeah hey [__] yeah dude I
was checking out it was just one guy
just being like you excuse me
dude that was it was a it was a polite
it was a polite heroin addict it was
kind of nice I'm sorry about that he was
completely just lost dude there was a
couple the whole time that'd be tough to
be a heroin addict and still have like
self-guilt like guilt and like aware
that you're causing a problem and he was
intensely aware of the fact that his
presence was a burden on but it was just
because no I've never seen one that has
that awareness dude the other two there
was a couple it was a you know doing a
girl the dude just kept going like baby
the hair white Heron addict dudes talk
like like 30s Jazz musicians they're so
smooth they got him they gotta keep your
baby in line you kept being like baby
babe don't worry I'll get the juice for
us honey baby
we got some stuff outside they really do
all right now steal that we got a heroin
out front we're gonna do some heroin in
five minutes and she kept trying to pump
steal those dunkaroos
steal that box of dunkarooses baby ah
they locked them up
stole too many dunkaroos man gushers
they get a Bach 24 pack of gushers just
heroin gosh dude they were talking about
snacks he was like they love snacks I
like the Cherry ones Alice is obsessed
with his iPad we have to we have to say
eyeballs his eyeballs too but he's
obsessed with it so we have to like you
know like ration the time like you can't
be on it all day yeah and he plays video
he loves it he's a [__] obsessed so
we try to you know parent when he can do
it so he here's this game where they he
wants to buy a block of some it's like
25 bucks or something so
Christina's like I don't want to just be
like yeah you know we should make him
like earn it I'm like yeah I go let me
talk to him so I was like I go what's up
he's like all right this thing's like 25
bucks he's like I think I should have to
you know like do chores and stuff like
oh yeah that's cool and he goes how long
like how long until I can get it I go um
he goes how about two weeks
and I go that seems fair
and then she gives he gives the phone
back to her she goes he doesn't
understand how long two weeks
it's just a word
and I was like yeah
who just heard it he's just heard it so
I was like no he's she goes
so I was like I go you sure she goes he
definitely doesn't
yeah
he does it so he gets him back to the
phone like he goes how many days is two
weeks
it's 14 he goes that's a long time
I go how about one week he goes how many
days is that
he doesn't know what a week is I got
seven days he's like no
I was like
I was like all right how about four days
it's so long oh
[__] oh [__] I wish I had that in my
life yeah so I [__] lovely settled on
four days
it's been [__] eight seconds
tell me what two weeks is your watch
oh [__] oh [__] that's so good oh I know
oh I should adopt a kid it was nice the
food suck ass really well you know
Hollywood people don't eat oh good point
they don't eat they don't swallow right
they don't want the real calories like
my ex
[Laughter]
are you just over there running your
mouth
playing the Joe games
I do that all the time like this is why
this is why it should have worked who
did somebody dump you no no I'm married
you married yeah sorry swallow the X the
X yeah so you didn't think this joke was
gonna be broken down
[Music]
who the [__] is he talking to I just
thought he was talking to somebody on
the wall I'm just making a joke
I enjoyed it it kind of scared me when
people just randomly running their
[__] mouth
um place as well you know people run
their mouth like there's something wrong
with that's what I'm looking like you
the [__] okay I probably have some
problems
because I need to know if I need to hit
you or get the [__] up
you just randomly a mission swallow who
the [__]
tell me what's going on I mean I'm you
ain't nobody invisible sucking your dick
is she No Yeah by yourself no no I'm
just joking around
didn't mean to scare you
a little bit you did you know you got
that little school shooter face
I never finished school
but
I'll just let's get some questions here
before our friend has to go
all right of course not never gets it on
the first play all right hi stop
um well first thing first is like
I guess
okay I have a I do have a boyfriend I'm
not guessing at this but I have a
boyfriend and recently I have just been
or like in the past year
and definitely buy nice but I have never
been with a woman I love my boyfriend
but I don't know if I could live with my
life without
um
having sex with a woman
um I just wanted to know what your
thoughts were on that whole situation
thank you have a good day bye okay this
is nice this is cute she's she's
realized something about herself she
wants to eat a little clam nothing wrong
with that we support that here yeah I
think the answer is simple uh
tell him and then start doing it
I think it's 15 minutes of your day
maybe the present presentation of it is
something in the realm of like uh you
know you kind of drop like a heavy
Hammer that's going to make him like
take a seat like okay I have a I'm where
he goes I'm having some feelings about
our relationship oh over here he goes
about like it goes I'm having experience
about you know being attracted to other
people and then when he sits down and
has to like oh my God he goes I think I
want to like try having sex with a woman
he's gonna he's gonna he's gonna take
out his electric guitar
you see the color come back to his lips
don't ever say something crazy I thought
you were gonna cheat on me
I'm gonna go [__] knock snaps with
some chick
he goes back to playing Xbox yeah he
doesn't even pause the game he goes
excuse me oh nice okay he almost made me
lose my place
have you ever gotten caught cheating on
somebody no I'm not a big cheater
[Music]
thank you
thank you I'll talk guys I don't look at
all these girls break out in hives I
feel like Sarah always said if I [__]
a woman on the road I would come home
and be like hey babe it was great
I'm sorry I legitimately think in 2010 I
popped anxiety from all that kind of
[__] yeah just like lying so much it
went [__] nutty but I remember did my
phone being missing one day it just it
simply fell in the crack of the cushion
on the couch where I was sitting but I
had friends over and no one knew what
was going on as I was frantically
they're like we're watching a Eagles
game or something they go oh that was a
good play I'm like uh-huh uh-huh super
good play I kept yelling for my ex to
see where she was and what her voice
sounded like
it's like Marco Polo
hey Carlos she's like yeah I'm like okay
nothing yet
I'm still trying to find this thing
what's up you want to hear my this is my
what closest I have to a cheating story
I had a girlfriend that I lived with and
I was bartending and this woman was like
God you're lying you're so adorable I
just want to kiss you on the face and I
was like wow you can and then she went
like like a closed lip like
and I was like whoa and then the next
day my appendix erupted and I was like
dude that was [__] crazy that was
like karma [__]
and I was like I can't what am I gonna
do [__] a woman my dick will fall off
I'll get like you know pancreatic cancer
or something
I swear to God it was the next day I was
like oh my stomach is like killing me
yeah he's burst your own appendix with
anxiety with a smooch
you [__] [__] the lady's out of town
she's like I'm Going Up To Boston early
Easter's on Sunday I'll go there on
Friday and really milk it see the net
the nieces the nephews the aunts the
moms the dads the kin so I go all right
have fun I get the whole place to myself
and she goes it would mean a lot if you
came up Sunday and I was like well I got
shows Saturday night then I got to be
back here on Monday to pod she's like
well you know Sunday
it's my sister's birthday Easter I was
like oh man I said the only way I can do
it is if I rent a car drive there drive
back Sunday night be ready for Monday
morning she was like sounds good
see invoicester
comedy podcasting sets from April Big
Jay oakerson made the most guest
appearances last month going on what has
to be a record-breaking performance 18
total podcasts including are you garbage
take your shoes off The Joe Rogan
Experience this [__] podcast davi's
world you know what dude whiskey Ginger
the Adam Carolla show two bears one cave
breaking bread with Tom Papa skeptic
tank drinking Bros Howie Mandel about
last night out and about kill Tony and
KFC radio the most viewed episode from
last month was Stavros halcus on this
past weekend with Theo Vaughn that
episode is currently sitting at over 1.9
million views if you enjoyed this best
of April highlight video great news
there's a lot more where that came from
please consider subscribing to joke
world to stay in the comedy loop it's a
sports center for comedy WE Post
highlights like this all the time as
well as a comedy new show every single
Tuesday so if you want to know what's
going on with all your favorite
comedians all your favorite podcasts
look no farther than subscribing to joke
world turn on the post notifications
thank you for watching